To upload wireframes, JPEGs,
or PNGs simply drag and
drop your images directly
into your browser window, or
you can simply click Browse to select
screens you would like to import.
If you find yourself manually uploading
screens one by one, it may be a long and
cumbersome process, so you may consider
using EnVision sync as a method for
automatically uploading screens for you.
EnVision Sync can automatically detect
changes to the screens that you've saved
on a local folder on your computer, and
automatically import those
into EnVision for you.
The advantage of using
EnVision Sync is that you can
automatically have those screens
uploaded into EnVision so
you don't have to manually upload them
each time you want to create a project.
Once you've finished
uploading your screens,
you'll see a thumbnail preview of all of
your screens uploaded into your project.